[Música]
dada las circunstancias yo creo que los
más importantes para mí hoy es contarles
mi historia esto de la computación
cuántica queer esto va de que yo trabajo
haciendo una cosa que se llama
ordenadores cuánticos y de que soy una
mujer trans estos son muchos palabras
así que vamos a ir por partes en seis
colores yo soy una mujer trans queer
científica activista obrera y feminista
vamos a ir primero a la parte de la
charla que para algunos es la más
compleja que es qué es esto de
ser una mujer trans kurier yo nací bueno
yo soy una mujer pero cuando nací en el
hospital y en el registro civil se
empeñaron los señores de que yo era un
señor me pusieron asignada hombre y
enlace
entonces me tiré una buena parte de mi
vida yo intentando pues bueno me
creyeron intentando hacer quien no soy a
los 30 años más o menos en 2019 salgo
del armario y la verdad es que me da
bastante bien
mi pareja me lo toma muy bien me apoya
un montón mi familia me apoya un montón
mis amigos mi apoyo casi todo el mundo
que yo conozco me apoyo en el trabajo
mía pero en la calle me apoyaron en el
comercio me apoyaron la gente de barrio
todo maravilloso pero también les tengo
que decir una cosa y esto ya no les
quiero mentir será una mujer en ciencias
y ser trans es un poco duro aviso de
contenido vamos a hablar aquí de acoso
misoginia y de transfobia soy una de las
pocas mujeres trans en computación
cuántica en este continente y en el
mundo entero por lo cual a veces me
siento bastante solita de trabajo en un
poco complicado y esto es un poco más
enojan te meten más enfadada también me
acosan a mí en la vida me ha costado
mucho me han hecho mucho bullying en el
instituto y en más sitios pero
últimamente esto enfada parece que ha
ido más por ejemplo hace un año cuando
salí anuncie una charla aquí antes de
que regreso con usted salió un bulo en
internet diciendo que yo había robado
conseguido mi plaza a marie curie así no
debe pasar por señora pusieron detrás
velo para arriba me dijeron esto está
hecho pasa desde señora y la rama de la
zona mujer que pasa ni radar de inventos
que las plazas marie curie no son plan
pero son plazas que no tienen género
asignado pero no permitas que una verdad
arruine una buena historia esto es un
caso aislado el acoso es continuo en los
últimos años ha habido un incremento de
la violencia transfo con y del discurso
de odio de extrema derecha se han
difundido muchos bulos y muchas mentiras
acerca de una cosa que es la ley trans
es una propuesta de ley para proteger
los derechos humanos de las personas
trans de que no se nos discrimine y
entre otras cosas un derecho que se
llama la auto
terminación de género esto es el derecho
de las personas trans a ser quien es o
que no se les contradice de un dni donde
pongo el género suyo el que sea esto no
está aprobado en españa
en españa ahora nos exigen estar dos
años en hormonación lo cual es una
condición abusiva la reivindican muchas
organizaciones de derechos
internacionales como la convención
europea las naciones unidas o la güemes
pero dado el clima actual
la propuesta de ley está bloqueada ahora
vamos a hablar de esta otra parte de la
charla que yo hago ordenadores cuánticos
esto va de que yo intento hacer
ordenadores que funcionen más rápido
utilizando sistemas muy pequeños
sistemas como átomos y partículas
moléculas fotones estaba muy chiquito
que están muy bien ordenados y muy bien
controlados hoy en día podemos controlar
estos sistemas con luz electromagnética
o luz láser entonces cuando utilizamos
estos sistemas los ordenadores pueden
ser más rápidos esto es un poco raro
vamos a aplicarlo tiene que ver con una
cosa que los científicos llamamos la
coherencia
vamos a ver recordar entonces cuando
antes de el coronavirus algunos de
ustedes a lo mejor iban a bares a lo
mejor se reunían con una buena amiga y
se ponían a hablar de temas complejos
como feminismo tras inclusión y anti
capitalismo
esto es una situación donde podemos
tener una conversación elaborada que lo
física llamamos de coherencia
ahora bien qué pasa llegan los amigotes
nos tiramos mucho rato en el bar empieza
a ver ruido música alguien se ha tomado
dos bebidas azucaradas demás ya no se
entienden los dientes cristo ya no
nannini complejidad ni conversación ni
na na esto es una situación que les dice
que llamamos de incoherencia y que
ocurre a los átomos les pasa
evidentemente algo parecido si los
átomos están mezclados para remolina o
con mucho ruido no se van a comportar de
la misma manera que si están los ponemos
bonitos con la cerveza o cookie
ordenadito y como la foto de aquí de la
del estero entonces es la derecha o
izquierda en este lado tenemos un
gazpacho de ayuda temor y aquí los
átomos cookie a esto les pasa como a
vuestras amigas las madres del bar
tienen un espacio ordenado un espacio
seguro pues tiene una conversación más
rica más elaborada más compleja con más
matices que los átomos del otro lado
entonces cuando los átomos en esta
situación
vemos que pueden tener más más riqueza
más diversidad y vemos efectos nuevos
efectos que son más oscuros por ejemplo
tenemos un efecto que es la
superposición cuántica esto es una cosa
un poco extraña para algunas pero
resulta que en el mundo microscópico las
partículas los objetos los sistemas no
tienen propiedades bien determinadas la
posición de un átomo la velocidad de una
partícula o incluso el género de una
molécula a veces no es tan bien
determinado a veces tienen varios
valores a la vez a veces fluctúan una
cosa muy fluida entonces recordar esto
si alguna vez os encontráis un átomo por
la calle antes de meteros con el átomo
recordad que su género no tiene por qué
estar bien asignado es fundamentalmente
imposible sobre
respeto
también tenemos otro efecto que llamamos
el efecto túnel tiene un nombre muy
elaborado en realidad es como una
especie de cosas que hacer los átomos
que toman atajos imposibles ustedes
tiene aquí una pared normalmente la
pared no pueden cruzar la tele o los
átomos pueden atravesarla sin romperla
una cosa que sorprendía mucho a menos
que se ha ido algún pueblo del norte de
cáceres esto es una cosa que normalmente
es imposible los pueden cruzar pared
vale flipante y estas cosas son un poco
extrañas pero ocurren de día a día en el
mundo atómico y lo más curioso es que
tienen aplicaciones en tecnología por
ejemplo esto que tenemos aquí un láser
esto es una luz que se hace con un
fenómeno cuántico como la luz cuántica y
lo usamos todo el rato tiene mogollón de
aplicaciones yo por ejemplo estoy usando
para quitarme aquí los pelos de la barba
aunque se resisten pero bueno es una
cosa más o chulo que todos conocemos
pues es una tecnología cuántica y los
físicos están investigando cómo usar los
mismos efectos para hacer otras
tecnologías comunicaciones o ordenadores
entonces yo lo que hago es usar esos
mismos efectos de efectos que hacen
la luz láser para acelerar los cálculos
un poco el truco es que estos atajos
imposibles que toman los átomos o los
aprovechamos en una computación para
tomar un tiempo más corto los
ordenadores cuánticos parecen una
entelequia pero ya existen de hecho esto
que tenemos aquí es un chip es un
ordenador cuántico que sacó google es
uno de los más grandes del unir del
mundo y se hizo vibrar la zona un año y
medio estuvo muchísimo y las noticias
llegó a español llegó a todas partes
este ordenador cuántico de google
hubo mucho ruido mucho bombo porque
google tenía ya un ordenador cuántico
que pasan los ordenadores cuánticos de
hoy en día son un poco cutre este
cacharro tiene no tiene más de cientos
de bits cuánticos cuánticos pero los
ordenadores cuánticos hoy en día tienen
como muchos unos cientos de bits
eso no es mucho comparado con los
ordenadores que tenemos pero ya se están
utilizando estos ordenadores para hacer
cálculos relativamente elaborados en
investigación como son muy pequeños
otros estos ordenadores cuánticos no
sabemos para qué sirven entonces
perdonan aquí en granada
lo que hacemos es investigar para qué
sirven estos cacharros que son
ordenadores cuánticos relativamente
interesantes pero todavía bastante
primitivo si todo esto es muy complejo
recordad una cosa a quien somos la
competencia andaluza de google hacemos
ordenadores con verdadero poderío
cuántico cuyo andaluz
vamos a terminar la charla y vamos a la
parte de esta activista obrero feminista
aquí un aviso de contenido y vamos a
hablar de la cara fea de la ciencia
precariedad y acoso a todos nos gusta
mucho la ciencia bueno a mí me gusta
muchísimo me imagino que ustedes también
pero en la ciencia hay cosas que no
molan en la ciencia hay mucha
precariedad laboral trabajo temporal
contratos temporales hacemos muchas
horas extras tenemos un sistema
piramidal que dificulta la
estabilización y facilita porque los
salarios serían más baratos
la ciencia lo hace en persona las
personas tienen sexo porque hay en una
sociedad y reproducen los sexos de esa
sociedad en la ciencia también es estimó
racismo obvia transfobia capacit ismo
también hay acoso sexual y acoso esto es
muy duro pero estas cosas ocurren a
veces también porque la ciencia tiene un
sistema piramidal como decimos
en la ciencia es difícil pública es
difícil sobrevivir en general y si eres
parte de un colectivo infrarrepresentado
aún más en mi campo por darme una idea
el 90% de los 100 informáticas cuánticas
son señores blancos de clase media
piquetero sexuales son bajísimas
normalmente será bueno por aquí
probablemente sea muy majo pero no se
puede negar a veces que falta un poquito
de diversidad a mí me ha costado
sobrevivir en ciencia y de hecho me
dedico a hacer eventos donde intentamos
hacer conferencias que nosotros hablemos
de ciencias sino también de estos
problemas que afectan a las personas que
sean que trabajan en la ciencia entonces
lo que hacemos es conferencias donde
hablamos de después de físicas de
informática cuántica pero también nos
interesan mucho los colores y hablamos
otros temas como los derechos laborales
la diversidad la igualdad la inclusión o
la ética estáis invitados y más por
cierto con esto me gustaría terminar con
unas palabras la ciencia no es un lugar
es una gente la ciencia la hacen
personas una ciencia diversa y más
juntas es más justa y en mejor ciencia
- cuánticos son más ocurrir los
fenómenos cuánticos a pesar de que cerró
en cuyo también servir para hacerte no
lo
una de esas tecnologías son los
ordenadores cuánticos la computación que
explota efectos cuánticos para hacer
cálculos por ordenador se llama
computación cuántica
me dicen juan y todo esto es muy bonito
muy interesante pero para cuando
tendremos un ordenador cuántico con la
tecnología de juani ver mejor y yo digo
miren a mí no me gusta mentir los
físicos son malísimos prediciendo el
futuro
normalmente mentimos cuando decimos el
futuro más de 15 años pero yo tengo una
cosa un poco clara teniendo en cuenta
cómo avanza la ciencia y el ritmo al que
avanzan los derechos humanos en este
planeta seguramente tengamos ordenadores
cuánticos que la igualdad de género así
que un poco de optimismo señora muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]